today's episode is sponsored by blinkist
the app that lets you
read or listen to an entire nonfiction
book
in just 15 minutes you can try blinkist
totally free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
david pakman i put the link right below
this video
we are down to just the last four
days of this campaign but it may be more
than four days until we know the final
results in every state and that's okay
it's a modern thing that people even
expect to know the results on election
day and
this year in particular because there
are so many mail-in ballots because of
the global
100-year pandemic roughly 80 million
people
have already voted and some states like
pennsylvania because they don't start
counting those mail-in votes
until the polls close on tuesday might
not have results
for a few days and that's okay but it's
not okay for donald trump because that
is exactly
the window of opportunity he is planning
on to steal this election
here is donald trump don't take my word
for it here is trump himself
saying hopefully we will get courts to
stop
the counting of ballots that arrive
after election day or even just ballots
that arrived on time
but weren't counted before the end of
election day here's trump himself
saying it hopefully the few states
remaining that want to
take a lot of time after november 3rd to
count ballots that won't be allowed by
the various courts because as you know
we're in courts on that we just had a
big
victory yesterday in wisconsin on that
matter
so hopefully that won't be happening
okay now later on today
i'm going to talk about how of course
mail-in ballots should be counted
after election day as long as they are
postmarked by election day
you have the law is you have until
election day itself to vote
you shouldn't be penalized for delays in
the mail
but the point here is that donald trump
is not trying to hide it and when i've
asked
congresswoman debbie mccarsell powell
about this i asked mayor eric garcetti
about this i asked
congressman ruben gallego about this is
biden ready with lawyers
they all say yes he is and that may well
be true
but what if it gets to the supreme court
which now has
three of donald trump's nominated
justices on it and they get to decide
the outcome of these ballots in this
election
donald trump's plan is to block
legally cast ballots from counting that
is election fraud that is voter
suppression that is election
suppression it is against the law but
they are trying to build public support
for stopping the counting of these
ballots by pretending there would be
something wrong with counting them
after election day this is always the
case by the way that this happens
the only difference is that this time
there's more mail-in ballots than ever
because
of the pandemic and donald trump
although now his postmaster general says
he stopped
donald trump's postmaster general was
interfering with the post office's
ability to handle
mail so it might take a little bit
longer it might
actually make a difference in a couple
of states that we don't get all of the
ballots counted on election night now
some good news in terms of rulings the
supreme court late wednesday
said both north carolina and
pennsylvania will be
allowed to extend their arrival
deadlines for the mail-in ballots again
we're not changing the postmark date you
still have to fill it out and mail it
by election day but they are extending
the
transit deadline essentially
increasingly it really could be
pennsylvania that is the big one here
pennsylvania
could decide the winner in fact there's
lots of electoral vote scenarios which
we will go through
where it comes down to pennsylvania and
secretary of uh pennsylvan of the
commonwealth of pennsylvania
kathy buchvar said she expects the
overwhelming majority of votes will be
counted by friday november 6. it's just
a few days
but we could actually be waiting for
pennsylvania depending on how the
election goes i would prefer it not be
that close
but it might be eight states expect to
have at least
98 percent of unofficial results by noon
wednesday only eight 22 states in dc
allow postmarked ballots to arrive after
election day so the timing
is going to depend on when voters return
them
new york and alaska aren't going to
report any mail-in votes on election
night shouldn't make a difference
alaska's going to trump
new york is going very very powerfully
to joe biden full results from michigan
are expected to take several days if you
combine now
pennsylvania and michigan you really
have many scenarios
from an electoral map standpoint where
we don't know
the results until we know michigan and
pennsylvania
uh if you say at this point what are the
odds networks will announce
a president-elect on election night
i would say about 65 i think there's a
65 percent chance
it's it's not close and we know on
election night i think there's a 35
chance we know at some point after that
every vote must be counted
they are being clear about their
strategy and i
i really hope i know the members of
congress are telling me
biden's got the lawyers ready i hope he
has the right lawyers ready
i hope he has enough lawyers ready
because it's going to be a mess
during a senate hearing on uh wednesday
republican senator mike lee
i guess recovered from coronavirus said
fact-checking is a form of censorship
this is one of the guys who loves
wearing no mask he caught coronavirus he
went to a senate hearing didn't wear a
mask
despite having been diagnosed with the
virus just days earlier complete total
clown show
um on wednesday there was a hearing held
with the ceos of twitter facebook and
google
the topic was section 230 as you know
donald trump has been talking about
repeal
section 230. it relates to a legal
responsibility to social media companies
for the content that's published
but what it led to was a lot of
republicans going mask
off not just liter not just literally
but also mask off
figuratively here's mike lee saying fact
checking is a form of censorship
uh and when i use the word sensor here i
i mean uh
i mean block content fact check uh or
label content or uh demonetized websites
fact checking labeling something not
trustworthy saying something is untrue
it is all censorship to mike lee so let
me sort of interpret this for you
in realistic terms when your entire
world view is based on falsehoods
and your entire political movement is
based on lying to people in order to get
them to vote for you
yeah fact checking is a problem for you
but it's not censorship
if i say for example mike lee
perpetrated
the non-existent bowling green massacre
remember when uh
kellyanne conway made up the bowling
green massacre
if i say mike lee perpetrated that if i
get fact
checked is that censorship of course not
and ted cruz at the hearing stated
sort of uh uh he started going in the
same direction
really really dangerous now because you
are seeing more and more of the
republican party push this idea
republicans don't actually believe in
freedom of speech even though they claim
to be
the stalwart defenders of the
constitution they just want to be free
to lie to you
without anything making it tougher
for them to convince you of those lies
and in this case
the republican party wants to understand
what they're saying
legally force private businesses whose
rights normally they defend
they want to force private businesses
like facebook and twitter
to allow them to lie to you with no
consequences
i thought they were about deregulating
business
i thought they were about getting
government out of the business of
private industry
so to them every time someone interrupts
their lies
with reality we are infringing on their
right
to be ignorant of reality this is the
delusional backwards perspective that
they bring to the table on this issue
now
as far as section 230 is concerned
i don't know i mean this is a bigger
topic but
if you repeal section 230
you would probably see at least some of
these social media companies
be stricter police officers
so to speak of what is published to
their platforms
because they would be more cautious
about
possibly having consequences themselves
about untrue or defamatory information
being posted by individuals on their
platform so
this is a bigger topic and and you know
after the election
uh when things hopefully calm down we'll
have
actual maybe intellectual property
attorneys on to talk about it but
there's
actually a chance that repealing section
230 which trump has been talking about
may not be so good for the republican
lies that they are looking to spread uh
unfettered for lack of a better term but
that's a bigger conversation which we
will we will certainly have
let me know your thoughts i'm on twitter
at deepakman later today i will be
addressing a few
there have been some questions that a
lot of people have been asking me one is
david you criticized trump a lot on
kovid
but what would biden what should biden
have done differently
i will address that i've been getting
messages from people saying david
election day is it why should ballots be
counted after election day well
if they've been sent by election day
they should be counted and i will get
into that a little bit later today
uh and i will also take some of your
calls via discord
davidpakman.com discord that's
d-i-s-c-o-r-d
great program the last friday show
before the election the david pakman
show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly
what one of my favorite apps lets you do
it's called blinkist and what they do is
take thousands of popular nonfiction
books they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
non-fiction book
in just 15 minutes i recently read a
brief history of time of course by the
great stephen hawking this is a book
that i have been aware of for so long
and
other things got in the way and it was
fantastic to check it out on blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about
eight bucks a month and you get the
entire library
but you can try it totally free and get
25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
underneath this video
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
all right let's uh let's hear from some
people in the audience
this is the last opportunity before next
week's
election want to see what's on people's
minds of course now
using the david pakman show discord
server which you can find
at davidpakman.com slash discord
and lots of great conversation happening
there otherwise
let's first go to uh
let's go to ali from detroit ali from
detroit
you were on uh what's going on there
what's on your mind today
ally from detroit please unmute and you
can talk to me
sorry can you hear me now yes i can oh
i'm a big fan
thank you uh i was calling today
because i i wanted to ask like what do
you think about the filibuster
and what's the likelihood that that will
actually get repealed under
like a biden administration because i
have my doubts that
that the filibuster believe it will even
be gone
but i uh i have the same doubts i have
seen
so on on expanding the court i now feel
very strongly joe biden should do it i
don't buy the slippery slope arguments i
think it's completely warranted given
the way republicans have dealt with the
supreme court over the last four years i
think it's time
and i don't buy as i mentioned in a
commentary earlier this week that
every president then now is going to
expand the court on the filibuster i've
seen
better arguments for both sides but i
think the arguments will be moot because
i like you don't really think joe
biden's going to going to push for it
oh okay um oh and
another thing i was going to ask you is
um so do you think we could actually
like
make a progressive movement through a
biden administration because
i feel like after hearing aoc talk
earlier this week and saying how she's
planning to lobby him
towards her agenda when it comes to
uh fracking i just kind of have my
doubts that she'll even
or that anything like that will get done
well remember joe biden's joe biden's
idea you know
trump has made this big deal out of joe
said he would ban
fracking and then joe said he wouldn't
biden's
actual plan is to put us on a path to
get to 100
renewables which would simply phase out
fracking and everybody's focused on
is biden going to try to pass a law to
make it illegal in six months no he's
not going to do that
in either case the point is a framework
where we get away from fracking anyway
and so i don't see aoc's position as
completely antithetical to biden's
anyway the point is
will will he have the senate and what
can he actually get
through as a result of that i think it's
less about his ambitions than whether
it's actually feasible with the senate
okay um you know that's that's all i had
to ask you today i'm a big fan
i'm glad i got to talk to you all right
ali from detroit appreciate hearing from
you thank you so much
um let's go let's go next
to um let's go to lucas from copenhagen
one of my
favorite cities in the world lucas how
is copenhagen these days
hi can you hear me yes i can wow cool
that's awesome yeah
well um yeah i'm half i'm half german
half danish so um
yeah i'm i'm mixed so i'm um i'm
wondering what your take is on the whole
covet thing here in europe
i mean we're really in this second wave
now and uh
whole germany is talking about like a
mini lockdown or like
a yeah wave breaking thing i just want
to know what what your take is on that
and whether you think mine uh like a
lockdown would be
would be a good choice well listen i i
would i simply defer i
it would be inappropriate for me to say
whether i think a lockdown would be good
what matters is what do the public
health experts in each country say
spain is experiencing this france is
experiencing the
this one thing that's important to
remember as we compare what's going on
in the us to what's going on in europe
is that we are getting to wave three now
i know that you can say
wave one never really ended in the us
because we never got below 20 000 cases
a day
but the point is we had dips and we had
a spike at
000 to spike at 70 000 and now we're
having you know even 80
000 cases in a day so any comp
direct comparisons between the us and
europe
first of all need to be per capita but
secondly
you guys actually suppressed the second
wave
all summer you're only getting the
second wave now
we're already on wave three and so i
think that we should all be careful
to be making any direct comparisons
because europe we're on
we're one wave ahead of you and
hopefully you will never
have a third wave that would be the hope
of of taking measures now
yeah yeah i agree um and i had another
question um
so i had i heard this i saw this video
from uh john stossel i don't know if you
know him
i do know who he is yeah yeah yeah he's
a bit controversial right
yeah and he he had a video where he
talked about like a human challenge
trial
where volunteers would would be um
injected with covet
um do you think that's like any uh that
would be an option or you think that
that should be strictly written by
government yeah so this is a big medical
ethics topic which is
if you really want to be sure a vaccine
works or a treatment works you do a
challenge trial which is you
actually rather than waiting around to
see how many people get infected you
actually try to infect them
it's a big medical ethics topic i would
leave it to the public health experts
and medical ethicists it wouldn't
i would have nothing substantive to add
other than to say
this is not john stossel's idea the idea
of challenge trials has been around
a really long time yeah yeah that's it
i mean all right my friend great by the
way have you ever been to
a place in uh a copenhagen called
fisk bar this far no no i haven't
all right i recommend the fish and chips
there if you make it okay
cool yeah very good to hear okay all
right thanks so much great to hear from
you
um let's see where else we want to go
today
uh there's just all sorts of different
people here
um let's go oh i want to hear from from
brooklyn let's go to mo
from brooklyn mo how are things there i
was seeing some of my brooklyn friends
posting videos of double lines around
voting buildings like the line goes
around once and then there's it's like a
concentric line around that
yes absolutely it is really uh
i'm happy to see so many people waiting
in line
i mean recently a few days ago i
actually voted in brooklyn
yeah in brooklyn college and the line
was pretty big i make sure to get it
kind of
around where the polling place is closed
yes because
i knew that the turnout wouldn't be
would kind of go away near the end you
know people are leaving
and it was um it was a cool thing
now you're talking brooklyn college is
that you're talking about like uh
near borough hall right nearby
not exactly oh okay it's on campus road
near at the near
brooklyn law school sorry okay yeah
flatbush okay yeah
so in that neighborhood right now are
things are things relatively open or is
there still stuff that's shuttered
altogether
oh no things are very open very
yeah i mean yeah i mean
they obviously are operating very safely
of course
but things are open nonetheless but i
actually didn't have a question i just
want to tell you something
please is that is that your repetition
of
telling people to vote it has worked on
me
really see i was i was in new york and
of course
biden is going to win new york in a
landslide yes
but because i'm uh i'm on the david
pakman subreddit
i'm on reddit a lot a lot of
left-leaning subreddits and i hear you
know
i see a lot of memes posted about vote
voting for example
on the stephen kenneth destiny bonnell
the second subreddit
on the large subreddit and on the day of
david pakman subreddit
right and seeing all these memes
has actually convinced me to go vote so
this is actually something and this is
something that trump
actually knows is that if you say so
like repetition is important when
delivering a message
rather than lies but it is true that
repetition works i think we should
repeat
truths like everybody should vote rather
than lies but
yes i think trump and i both understand
that
yes and that's what i want to say man
all right well i'm glad you voted let's
hope for
a blowout in new york i believe we will
get it
yes absolutely all right thank you so
much great to hear from you
um we are hearing from people via
discord
davidpakman.com discord let's go to
lives in salt lake city
uh i don't know that we get too many
callers from utah
liz tell me what's going on there and
you please do set you
to do not disturb i'm already before
even hearing you hearing your discord
bleeping and blapping so please set that
to do not disturb and i would love to
hear from you
hey david hello hello hey um so i'm
calling in from salt lake
and i was just curious what are the
chances that donald trump and his family
will be uh prosecuted after leaving
office i think it's very low
i i do believe that there's a good
chance
that there's going to be all sorts of uh
investigation
and maybe even settlements or fines for
donald trump's businesses
i really don't see criminal charges
coming
for the trump family it's not the way
this country has operated i'm not saying
it shouldn't
i'm just saying i don't expect it to
happen
okay and i've got one more question for
you um
what are the chances that uh don jr is
gonna run for office in the future and
you know what state do you think will
accept him and make that a reality an
unfortunate reality that he might run in
the future
well what do you mean what state will
accept him
like uh where does he have a chance of
running will he get like a second home
and
become a resident of like alabama or
something oh you're saying he's
you're but would he be running for
president or for senate
senate maybe like governor working his
way to
the white house he was ambitious
especially
oh he does his speech just and how he
supports his dad so i was just curious
like
who will accept him and do you think he
has a future in politics
i don't see it but i you know i think
he's pretty self-serving and
i think at this point we would be naive
to say he has no future and in fact when
i talk about the importance of removing
trump now
if we don't i think that 2024
much more naturally leads to a trump
kid running for something and so as as
much as it is important to vote trump
out now
for the sake of the world it's important
to vote trump out now
to not allow one of the kids an easier
path in 2024. i think that
if it listen if the republican party
voted for trump in the republican
primary
they would potentially vote for don jr
as well and we've got to make sure we
don't we don't
make that any easier for them
hello okay all right uh liz is gone i
guess so very very good
uh important question very very
important question
let me go next to cooper
from texas cooper from texas tell me
what's going on there
holy crap david we're purple you guys
are purple
i know yeah texas is in play that's
amazing yeah you know i'm i'm not very
old but
from my parents and and even my
grandfather and grandmother
never would have thought that texas
would be in the state it's in right now
now i think we want to be realistic you
know it's not
if if biden i think biden does not win
texas
in the end but the fact that it's this
close is incredible and you know what
maybe he will win it'll it'll be a
historic blowout we just don't know yet
but everybody has to vote
um i really wanted to uh ask you to
explain because i remember in your last
video you remarked to some extent that
you said um
you're more for expanding the court now
than you've ever been yes could you
could you expand on that some more
because i'm i'm very on the fence
about something like that okay so i did
a segment earlier this week on it which
has not yet uh which
is is on youtube by the time this call
goes live it will be on youtube but
you've obviously not seen it yet
uh one of the main arguments against
expanding the court from the right is
that it's somehow oppressive
undemocratic unconstitutional the
reality is despite losing
the popular vote in six of the last
seven presidential elections
republicans have selected the
overwhelming uh a
majority of recent picks to the court
that's not democratic number two
many presidents have added or reduced uh
seats
on the supreme court so it's not a
historical and number three there's this
slippery slope argument
that if biden adds some seats the next
president with that will add seats the
next president will add seats the next
president will add seats the reality is
you need the white house the house and
the senate to do it
that in itself reduces the opportunity
for it to happen
and i don't believe the public would
accept
expanding the supreme court indefinitely
i believe
in 2021 if joe biden wins and democrats
take the senate
the public will understand the travesty
that has happened over the last four
years and they will be okay with
expanding the court i don't buy the
slippery slope argument so i am now
very strongly for it okay
and and just one last thing and i'll
give a give up the air time
what do you think um the chances are of
another trump electoral victory if if he
were to let's say cut
biden's leads across the board by like
three points something insane like that
if biden's lead drops by three by
election day
i think trump's shot at an electoral
victory becomes effectively 50 50.
okay yeah all right thank you all right
my pleasure great to hear from you
uh let's take a quick break uh if you're
holding on to talk to me
don't hang up because we are going right
back to the phones after this short
break
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on your
support and the easiest way
is through membership which includes the
world famous bonus show as well as
commercial free audio and video streams
of the show
just for members sign up today at
joinpakman.com
coupon code saves you 40 vote soon 18.
welcome back to the david pakman show
we are taking a tour of the country
really of the world
hearing from different folks via discord
davidpakman.com
discord we are going to go
next to rob from virginia
rob from virginia what is going on with
you
rob from virginia you were on with the
opportunity to talk to me if you unmute
yourself and configure a mic i would
love to hear from you
and rob from virginia last opportunity
and rob is gone let's instead go to
ryan from massachusetts ryan from
massachusetts you were on
oh my god no way you actually picked me
um
i'm a huge fan of the videos and uh i
just had a question
on the hunter biden scandal
so i wanted your thoughts on that if you
thought it was just a big
whole sham um if because i watched some
of the interview
with uh tucker carlson yep and
uh one of uh biden's uh uh hunter
biden's associates
tony i forget his name bobo
yeah that's what it was yeah so i just
wanted your thoughts on that
if you thought it was um like a big
scam just like how in 2016 with hillary
and russia
and all that i wanted uh i was wondering
if you thought it was like the same
thing
so listen the i i am sure
that by mere chance there are
some assertions that have been made by
rudy
the new york post bob babalinsk you know
whatever i'm sure that there are some
aspects
and they could be relatively innocuous
that are true
about some of this but
understand that the story starts with
the idea
that we learned about this because
hunter biden
flew across the country to have three
laptops repaired by a legally blind guy
who despite admitting he didn't actually
see
hunter biden because he's legally blind
a bo biden foundation sticker on the
laptop makes him sure it was hunter
biden
and the guy when hunter biden never
picked up the laptops he flew across the
country to have repaired
uh accessed the private emails
and then gave them to the fb i mean you
know it's it's outrageous
and so i i you know if you say
did hunter biden was he really working
with burisma it's like okay yeah that's
true
um yeah but it the story they are
telling is such
obvious desperation everybody who's
tried to corroborate it
can't do it it's wacky i know i was just
wondering if you thought like people
would actually like believe that and
that could have an effect on the
election
so there's two questions there do people
believe it yes
there are people on the trump side who
are convinced about it
is it going to affect the election i
really don't think so i really don't
this is an
election that is so qualitative in
what's going on it's about the pandemic
it's about the economy
i don't think this is at all like the
hillary's email story
which really did get some uh some hold
definitely yeah um yeah thank you for
answering that um
i just ah man i forget my other question
now well your first one was so good you
i would go out on top if i were you
okay yeah rather than risking an
inferior question
yeah um all right
i'm gonna help you my friend i really
appreciate the call and i hope to hear
from you again
all right thank you so much yeah he was
gonna go and then end up
going out lower and we don't want that
so i think we're going to keep it going
this way
let's go to teresa from austria theresa
what is going on there hi david can you
hear me
i can i i think we had a problem
connecting last time you called in but
now you're coming in crystal clear yes
i was i'm usually not a discord user and
i
just downloaded it for uh the vice
presidential election
right so i was yeah um
i actually um pretty much wanted to give
you guys a heads up
um i'm really nervous for you
um when it comes to the election um
and actually i wanted to ask do you see
an
end for the electoral college at any
given point because i feel like
um due to the electoral college uh the
whole
um idea of democracy is
kind of at risk and is really
susceptible
for corruption and i think amy coney
barrett is
very corrupt i think the whole trauma
administration is to be frank
um in my opinion pence is just a robot
or a puppy to trom so from an
outstanding point
it looks really bad what's going on yeah
well listen
the what you're the republican party
wins elections because of the electoral
college so they don't want to get rid of
it if we had popular vote in the united
states
we would have had fewer republican
presidents so the republican party is
going to fight to the death to keep the
electoral college i think the best
chance to get rid of it is through
something called the national popular
vote interstate compact i won't go into
it now but it's basically if enough
states decide
to go popular vote in terms of awarding
their elect
electoral votes you de facto have a
national popular vote
um but i think that it will be very
difficult to get rid of the electoral
college any other way even that way it
will be difficult but we should get rid
of it it is
outdated and it is anti-democratic yeah
and we're allowed to vote with
uh 16 years of age in austria so i think
that would actually
turn around this election a lot because
i feel like the very young voters
yeah would have such a big outcome in
this election or in any election
actually
i agree with you teresa what part of
austria are you in
i live in lower australia i'm actually
just like 20 minutes away from vienna
okay i was scheduled to be in austria in
august
this past august there's a beautiful new
non-stop flight from boston to vienna
which has now been canceled because of
the virus
it all exploded but i was going to be in
vienna i was going to be in salzburg
i was so looking forward to it it'll
have to be some other time
i love boston too i was in au pair
massachusetts actually
no no way and i i loved it it's far more
european than
what i would have thought absolutely
absolutely that's especially what we say
to texans we're very european in boston
and they
they just think we're [ __ ] you know
all right theresa thank you so much
great to hear from you
thank you for taking my call my pleasure
all right teresa from austria what a day
what a day let's go to scott from
trenton
scott from trenton what is on your mind
hi good morning can you hear me yes i
can hear you
excellent i just wanted to know um
coming from i'm from canada and i'm just
wondering how
you have 40 percent of the population
who
actually supports donald trump and
what do you think that they're going to
do say
when biden wins so this is trenton
ontario is that what's going on
yes uh okay i i couldn't see it i
assumed it was maybe uh
new jersey it would be right there's a
trenton in new jersey i think
in any case listen i understand your
shock and amazement that
you know tens of millions of people in
this country are voting for donald trump
i have raised this issue many times if
biden wins and let's not assume but if
biden wins
what happens to those 60 million people
in the interim period
between election day and inauguration
day i believe there's a real possibility
that they become violent including with
firearms
beyond that i don't know what happens
you know they
uh i think a lot of them are going to
pretend like they never really supported
trump
some of them may split off into some
kind of q anon
conspiracy rabbit hole that maybe at
some point will become a more formal
political movement
it's very very difficult to say but
they're going to be here and we're going
to have to deal with it as a country and
i don't know exactly how we do that
yeah i i just i watch your show or
listen to your show all the time
and i i'm just genuinely concerned that
um the us has
withdrawn its role as being the leader
of the free world and
um what's what's going to happen
i just don't know how it proceeds or
progresses from here
i don't know either i'm just so what i'm
trying to do is to
take it step by step have i voted yes
okay i did that
uh next let's see what happens on
tuesday and then we'll
continue to to make plans after that
yeah hey well big fan thanks for taking
my call appreciate it great to hear from
you very very much
let's go next to stephanie paul
from paris france one of my favorite
places in the world stephanie i'm so
jealous of you
oh thank you very much david um i've
been listening to the show for
quite think about two years now so it's
uh it's absolutely fascinating thank you
uh the question i wanted to ask you is
how
on earth did amy kearney barrett
actually get elected or put into her
position because
in 2016 i think when barack obama wanted
to do the same thing
the republicans blocked him or at least
didn't want it to happen
and barack obama seemed to have just
been like oh okay i won't do it then
yeah it doesn't it doesn't seem that way
doesn't it yes
it's bizarre no you're you are this is
perfect because
you're getting exactly it's like what
what exactly happened like
they got away with it they cleared they
came up with the republicans in the
senate came up with a bogus reason to
block merrick garland in 2016.
and then now they said oh that
explanation
that doesn't really matter and with a
week to go before the election
they confirm amy coney barry it's it's a
travesty
and this is why uh joe biden if elected
and if democrats take the senate should
expand the supreme court
period full stop that's it but your your
your despondency over what happened
is accurate but he
they they can't get her out of power now
that she is actually
in it she could be impeached she could
be impeached theoretically but that
never happens you know
okay perfect thank you so much it's a
pleasure to speak with you stephanie
wait before you go
so it sounds so it sounds like from your
accent you're french but you learned
english in the uk is that correct um i'm
i'm half and half actually yes wow and
what is paris like the best of both
worlds or the worst of what
how is paris it's a little bit
sad actually there's a lot of um
a lot of confusion as to uh what are the
new rules going to be or we're going to
have a lockdown are we going to have a
lockdown
just for the weekend that's one of the
ideas that has been floated
um at the moment there is a sense of a
lack of control
but at the same time i think
macron has done in my personal opinion
a better job than many other leaders yes
i'm not
100 sure how or why the virus is
propagating
as much as it has and is doing now
um but uh i am amazed
that we france has uh
is unfortunately going through such an
increase in numbers that we're seeing
we had 500 plus deaths today potentially
uh
yeah we have been having numbers in the
14 48 000
uh which is unprecedented we didn't even
have this at the height of the lockdown
right a few months ago so it's very
worrying there's a real sense of
fatigue and stress but you know
parisians will continue to
be president
right and listen let me ask you this
when i when i go
uh to paris i often will stay in the
area of
belleville or republique are those
actually
those are those that's where you live
beautiful and let me ask you this have
you ever been
to a restaurant i believe it is called
ravioli chinois
of course yes please tell the audience
there are no better dumplings than at
that restaurant is that correct
it's fabulous and actually there's a
it's run by a family
yes and they make all the dumplings
fresh during the day
right there is a set number of dumplings
made when they're finished they're
finished
so you know it opens at 7 30 p.m
sharp and all the dumplings are gone by
maybe 10 30.
now let me ask you one other question do
you get the dumplings
steamed or grilled you can choose
no no i know that i know i'm asking what
do you do what do you mean personally
um i really like the schweitzer
that's the water the boiled dumplings
ah okay i tend to go more for grilled
but that's okay it's not a huge point of
disagreement
i i lived in northern china for a long
time and that's how we uh that's how we
would have them there
that's fair yeah the grill does not seem
authentic chinese but i do like it
stephanie i so appreciate hearing from
you today
thank you so much david have a good day
to you you too wow wow
things happening in paris what what a
tragedy that i am not there
let's go next to nick from ohio nick
from ohio what's going
on david can you hear me i can hear you
loud and clear my friend
it's such a pleasure to speak to you i'm
such a big fan of beta male and plasma
and all your other work plasma's huge
right now
hey so i've been pretty upset recently
with um
how democrats pelosi schumer how they're
dealing with um
amy coney barrett i i heard nancy talk
on a show maybe you heard this clip she
said she was asked by i forget who it
was
cnn msnbc something she was saying
we have arrows in our quiver to stop acb
from going through
yeah to stop this you know unjust
justice
from happening i i watched closely
after that to see you know we have heard
you talk about it on your show people
talk about our other shows like
impeaching bar and teaching trump again
holding quorums and forums
anything anything to take precedent over
putting in amy coney barrett so i'm
wondering what how
as a young person in this coming into
this new election
how am i supposed to have a trust in
these democratic leaders to
to to hold true to their word to
actually take action when it counts i
i just i can't be the only one feeling
just incredibly disheartened
disheartened and disappointed well
that's that's exactly this is
this is a great question basically this
is why
we shouldn't deify any politician we
shouldn't believe
any politician is going to do the things
they say they're going to do
and there are people who will
strategically apply that oh
bernie supporters say biden won't really
do the stuff he says or
republicans say well uh uh trump
the things that he says he's going to do
that are bad he's not really
whatever this is the whole point we need
to just think about our vote
as a tool to try to get something from
our elected officials and to have a plan
to hold them accountable
democrats blustered about we might be
able to block it this way or that
now in their defense most democrats said
i don't think we have the votes to stop
it that was that was the reality and
that that was true
uh but you're absolutely right that
everybody wants to pretend to be all
powerful
and in the end it's a you know
repetition of the status quo
so we can't change everything overnight
but all we can do is who can we vote for
that will accomplish something that
moves things in the way we want to see
and then we make another decision and as
barack obama said and then you vote
again
and then you vote again but you're
completely right the deification of
anybody
as completely trustworthy as a
politician whether it's trump or biden
or
tulsi or yang or whoever you know
that's that no that's not the way we
should be approaching approaching the
political world
and uh you you seem to have figured that
out astutely so
great well i have one other quick thing
to add to that i saw that there was a
rule that the house
the democratic house or something
there's some kind of law where two of
the members had to be present for the
senate
uh uh process to even go through yeah
and of course of course mitch just
waived that because
democrats could have just chose to not
com uh you know be complicit at all
right so so i you know when those when
that rule of law starts getting
i just hope that that we can find a way
to hold these people accountable and
you know there's the subreddit keep
track there's all these different ways
that we can keep track of all the the
the minutiae the the small ways in which
uh our democracy is being dismantled so
so yeah well thank you david i really
appreciate you taking the call and i'm a
huge fan then
thank you so appreciate it love the
energy
uh great talking to folks we will go to
a break and we will take
calls again but it's going to be after
the election
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
the david pakman show depends on the
support of our viewers
and listeners and one way to keep us
going is through
patreon where you can pledge as little
as one dollar per month
or as much as you want at patreon.com
davidpakmanshow great perks and benefits
as well
read about them
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
all right let's get into audience
questions for the week
uh just days left until the election
many election related questions
including first and foremost david i've
heard you criticize
donald trump's response to the virus and
i agree with you
it has been terrible but if joe biden
becomes president in january
what should he do then that donald trump
has not done
so two-part question first of all is the
vast majority of the things that should
have been done should have been done
previously and this includes
establishing contact tracing
early on building testing capacity
early on the way that south korea did
telling the truth early on about the
seriousness of the virus a lot of these
things
in other words most people now
understand the seriousness of the virus
there's less to do
on that front although you still have a
lot of trump's followers who don't
believe it it would be great to have to
have a president in who tells the truth
but
there is no question that the time to do
things was 2020.
not 2021 which is when joe biden will
actually
get to do something now by january 21st
hopefully we would start to be on the
other side of spike number three which
is building right now
hopefully by january 21st there will
already be
some people vaccinated and more people
getting vaccinated
every day so the things that joe biden
will have to sort of
think about or contend with will be
number one
restoring our public health officials
who are
actually infectious disease specialists
to positions
where they are speaking to the country
dr anthony fauci
was removed from that position by trump
and blocked from doing interviews
and so on and so forth he put in
neuroradiologist scott atlas who wants
herd immunity
and questions masks and whatever else so
we've got to change
who is publicly speaking to the country
from the standpoint of public health
stop lying about the virus constantly
get a stimulus bill done
if indeed we need one january
21st and that's something that a
president biden would have to look at
evaluate whether the request
for mask mandates should be made
remember
the the consensus constitutionally seems
to be
that a president cannot federally
mandate everybody wear a mask there
would be two ways to do it one is a
president would say
to all 50 governors hey guys and gals
please do mask mandates if we all do
this
for six weeks we will dramatically
reduce
the spread it would be up to governors
to do it or
work with congress so that through the
commerce clause congress can
regulate commerce in such a way that
would allow
some kind of mass mandate but a
president unilaterally doing it doesn't
appear as though they can do it
this is the way it would have to be done
biden's going to have to evaluate
the situation if and when he gets sworn
in and go from there
you know things like a national contact
tracing system
the the unfortunate reality it would be
great to do it
the unfortunate reality is that contact
tracing
once you have overwhelming community
spread where even relatively rural parts
of the country
have a huge number of cases contact
tracing becomes less
important at a at a systemic public
health level
it should still be done but again the
time to do it was
in february and march um increased
transparency on the numbers
because now many people don't trust the
numbers
um actually work with other countries
as opposed to saying we're blocking
china
we're blocking europe everybody that
americans get blocked from going places
actually start to work with other
countries on a coordinated response
planning for what things will start to
look like as we can hopefully at some
point next year
begin to loosen travel guidelines so on
and so forth
assure us of the safety of the vaccine
in a trustworthy way
as you all know without being anti-vaxx
anybody who has followed the lies of
trump would be skeptical about
saying on trump's say-so that a vaccine
is safe so there are lots of things to
be done but we also have to recognize
that
we we talk about climate change
irreversible damage and when
someone else comes in they have to start
trying to clean up a situation that was
worsened not under their watch a lot of
the things on coronavirus had to be done
when australia did them when new zealand
did them when south korea did them when
taiwan did them bangladesh
etc um by the time joe biden is in
office
those things aren't the things anymore
and it will be about figuring out going
forward
how to restore trustworthiness and a
sense of professionalism
to the white house in its coronavirus
response
and it's going to be an uphill battle
there's no doubt about it but
every day every day we wait is another
day trump's federal government
pushes us in the wrong direction david i
understand voting by mail
but why should states accept ballots
after election day
after all election day is election day
fair question let's assume you're asking
it in good faith
the uh the population that wants to vote
should be allowed to vote up until
election day
and if you want to vote absentee
you should be allowed to do it so the
only possible correct solution
is as long as your ballot has been sent
by election day it should count and in
particular
when you think so before i go further
if the ballot has to be received by
election day as is the rule in some
states and i disagree with it
you really only have until if you assume
it could take four days for the ballot
to be delivered
you really only have until october 30th
the 31st to vote but
election day is november 3rd why should
you be denied
by four days when you can send in your
ballot
if you are still able to do it before
election day
by election day you should be allowed to
do it now on top of that
when you recognize the way in which the
postal service
has been attacked by donald trump's
postmaster general he now says
that he's not doing any more stuff do we
trust it do we not listen there's just
questions
we don't want votes to be able to be
disqualified
just because the postal service delays
the mail
if the ballot is postmarked by november
3rd
that is what should matter now if you
want to be really cynical
the post office could as they gather the
ballots on november 2nd and november 3rd
wait until november 4th and postmark
them then and get them disqualified that
way
we're now talking about a more sort of
uh invasive
level of suppression but there is really
no good reason for which
you should not have your vote counted as
long as you send it
by election day we have a pandemic
expecting more vote by mail than ever
we're already seeing it we've already
seen
by some reports more than 60 million
votes already cast could be
close to half of the total or electorate
it's unbelievable numbers
we want to make sure these votes are
counted and if you vote by november 3rd
it should be counted
one last thought not only are we going
to see more vote by mail than ever
before
we are going to see a lot of new voters
voting for the first time by mail
some mistakes are going to be made and i
believe that
we should as if we have the goal
not of being ticky tacky and figuring
out ways to disqualify ballots which is
what republicans want to do
what i want to do is we should do
everything we can
to get as many people as possible
legally voting
we want time for people who make
mistakes
on their ballots to be notified
and to be able to resubmit or decide to
go in in person and
i know that that'll sound weird to a lot
of people who want to be very very
litigious and
regimented and strict father morality
sort of approach
if we believe that democracy is best
served by high voter participation and i
do believe that then
we should be doing everything we can to
get as many people to successfully vote
period and if you believe that you of
course
should be allowing every vote to be
counted that is postmarked by election
day
okay another question that came in um
if trump loses to biden in a few days
how will trump
trump is justify it this is a great
question because
you have you know just look at our
youtube comments look at the emails and
tweets that i get
david you're going to cry on election
day when joe biden loses
trump's got this thing wrapped up biden
has no chance
trump's going to win easily all of this
different stuff and i am not saying
anything other than the polls look good
for biden but it could go either way
so i i have taken a position that
is based on the facts no trumpist can
know
that donald trump is going to win and
indeed if donald trump loses
they're not going to say hey you know
what biden ran the better campaign and
more people wanted biden to win biden
won
that's not what trumpists are going to
say they have such
cognitive dissonance that you are going
to see them come up with
things you can imagine and things you
can't imagine some trump
if biden wins will say biden cheated and
by cheated they might mean
stuff with absentee ballots they might
mean uh
manipulating voting machines they
facebook who knows what but biden
cheated is going to be one
story that we are going to hear um okay
biden won but only because of the fake
news media that promoted him at every
opportunity you're gonna see a lot of
that
people going after the media saying the
media helped joe biden win
you were going to hear biden didn't
really win
trump didn't really lose not from the
standpoint
of cheating but from the standpoint of
it is just a fake story trump really won
even though it's being reported that joe
biden won you're going to see some of
that
you will then see it's sort of like a
the the
five stages of grief uh denial anger
bargaining dab duh denial angle bargain
d what's the depression and then
acceptance
you will start to see some people say
trump didn't want to win anyway
trump didn't they're going to be
rationalizing and trump did
trump had his four years he didn't have
to do this he had a great life
beforehand he's a rich guy
now he's going to go and make america
great by starting some tv network or who
knows what you are going to see that
absolutely for sure
and then you are also going to see some
people who say covid
trump's already been laying the
groundwork for it saying
we had the greatest economy i had great
popularity
and then the virus hit the plague came
in from china as donald trump says
and while if trump had handled it
properly he would be sailing to
reelection we've seen
when a world leader deals with the virus
well
they sail to re-election look at jacinda
ardern in new zealand as an example
trump could have done that but you will
see people say
hundred-year pandemic just got hit with
the plague
and that is why donald trump lost
otherwise he would have won it doesn't
really count as
a loss they will say i want to hear from
you
what other explanations are we going to
hear from trumpists and
some we won't hear anything from because
they will disappear
we we will never hear from them again
they will get off
the social media retweeting a fake news
they will stop doing all they're just
going to disappear we're never going to
the ones that are really just
embarrassed are going to disappear many
will come up with excuses let me know
what you think those excuses will be
we have a great bonus show for you today
the last friday bonus show
before the 2020 election senate election
congressional election presidential
election
many ballot measures local races so much
friday bonus show today and then it is
election week
i will see you then
thanks so much for watching today's full
episode of the show just a reminder
today's
sponsor is blinkist the app that lets
you read or listen
to an entire non-fiction book in just 15
minutes you can try blinkist for free
and save 25 percent off of a
subscription
when you go to blinkist.com david pakman
i've also included the link right
underneath this video